today we're gonna look at the fact that
all prime numbers when you square them
are one more than a multiple of 24 which
a lot of people don't believe it you are
shocked when I first told you about this
you are you're beside yourself because
people think the prime numbers haven't
got a pattern like a lot of emails from
people saying oh I found a pattern the
prime numbers are like yes there are
loads of patterns in the prime numbers
and including this one which will test
so Brady what prime number should we do
with the black sharpie
let's do 17 7.5 okay 17 squared equals
okay so it's gonna be no I can do this
cuz squares gonna be a hundred and
seventy plus seven times that which is
gonna be seventy plus 49
okay so just off the top of my head at
work was that I'm sorry seven eight
twelve thirteen okay I think it's
roughly that's not right seventeen times
17 equals to 8 now I was right doubted
myself and so I'm saying that's one more
than a multiple of 24 and so we can
split that apart because we've got 240
hidden in there plus 49 left over and
that's one more than 48 which is a
multiple of 24 and so this whole thing
here is gonna be as 12 times 24 plus one
so I argue any prime number you give me
if you square it you'll get some mobs
pull of 24 plus 1 on the end 5 5 is 25
that's one more than 24 you could have
opened with that Brady but now we do 17
first it doesn't work if you go back up
and do 2 or 3 so 2 or 3 don't work too
small too small and I mean I argue that
they're not real prime numbers I call
them the subprimes so I would like to
ignore those for the purpose of this
they don't work everything 5 onwards
this always works but we should prove it
right you didn't take my word for these
things so it comes down to when I first
saw this first of all I was amazed and
then I was like what hang on there must
be a reason why there's this pattern is
that there are loads of patterns in the
prime numbers so there's a nice one
involving multiples of 6 and because 24
is a multiple of 6 I was like you know
what that might be something to do with
it so I'm gonna recreate list out a
number line 11
12 13 18 19 okay so we got those and
then let's find our favorites the primes
we've got the subprimes hanging out down
here and then we've got the real primes
there's five there seven there
11 13 17 19 and so on and you go right
where are the multiples of six there's
multiple of six there it's six look at
that there's a prime on either side of
it right so those two either side of
multiple six there's the next multiple
of six look at that there's a prime on
both sides of it nothing else in between
next mode will six over there look at
that there's a prime on each side of it
so the primes are always above and below
all the multiples of six except doesn't
always work so if I kept going the
number layer stopped at 19 so 23 is a
prime 25 is not a prime there is our
next multiple of six and only on one
side do we get a prime 25 is not up
until now they have all been and the
reason this one isn't is 5 finally
caught up with us so 5 is prime but then
every 5th number isn't tens not 15 s not
20 s not boom so that's not this one out
the moral of story is not that there's
something magical about the primes and
they happen to always be above and below
every mod for 6 it's just that's the
only place they can be so here's a
multiple of 6 and here's the next one
they can't be at the even points in
between because we know Prime's can't be
even so immediately it knocks out these
two and it can't be the number in
between because multiple 3 number
between each multiple of 6 is multiple
of 3 so it can't be on any of these
which is why it has to be above or below
a multiple of 6 it's just a fancy way of
saying Prime's don't have 2 or 3 as a
factor and then to their constrain to
those and so people are happy if you say
all primes are odd ignoring the small
ones right and that's just because this
does nobody's saying Prime's haven't got
2 as a factor if you say all Prime's are
1 more or less than multiple of 6 and
was like wow but all we're saying is
they haven't got 3 as a factor and then
when we say all Prime's squared
give you one more than multiple 24 it's
a variation on this it just looks more
impressive and so the way I'll show you
the way I first worked it out when I
came across that I cuz like right I'm
going to prove this
delivery so here's what I did I said any
prime number other than two or three is
it either gonna be some molds pull of
six plus one or some multiple of six
minus one so every K we can put in one
of these two categories and so my
thought was I'll just square these and
show they're both one more one less than
a multiple of twenty-four but then they
didn't work out really really
complicated so I had another cheating
moment when I realized this K here is
either going to be odd or even so that K
is either gonna equal let's use skews em
this time to M or it's gonna equal this
is or to M plus one it's either even or
odd and so I can split each of these
into their two options so this one is
either gonna be if I put two M in there
it's gonna be 12 M plus one or if I put
in two n plus one it's going to be
twelve M plus seven and then down here
that's either going to be put into M
that's gonna be 12 and minus one or it's
gonna be 12 m plus six negative 1 5 okay
so now I know every single prime number
falls into one of these four categories
and so then I went through and I took
each of these and squared them to see
what happens when you square now this is
not exhaustive like an exhaustive proof
where I've checked every single option
I've just taken all the options and put
them into four categories and now I'm
going to check each of the categories
separately so let's do them quickly M
squared plus two times that time this
one's 144 m someone will correct me if
I'm wrong - tutors at times 2a plus 25
okay that's what we have to do now is
show that every single one of these is a
multiple of twenty-four plus one and the
first ones reasonabie straightforward
because that's a multiple of 24 because
that's 12 squares that's 6 times 24 so
we actually put 24
outside of that's gonna be 6m squared
plus M plus one so multiple Oh 24 plus
one this one is 24 outside of again 6m
squared plus seven M plus two plus one
so I've done theirs at 48
I've sorry that 49 I've realized is 48
plus one and so the 224 is the 48 plus
the one at the outside yeah same deal
again 24 outside 6m squared minus one
plus one
that's what mass m and finally 24
outside of 6m squared plus 5m plus 1
plus 1 so there I've taken every single
prime showing that must be in one of two
categories above or below modulo six
each of those has to be one of two
categories if that multiple six is even
or odd those four categories cover every
single prime I've then expanded them out
and shown that if you square them you
get some number times 24 Mobil 24 plus
one which proves it right it's a
slightly clever exhaustive proof where I
put it in categories and I've dealt with
the categories one at a time I was so
pleased when I got to the end is nigh
was like yep I knew it had something to
do with being one or more one less than
a multiple of six I did some algebra I
worked it out I showed some friends of
mine and one of them said why didn't you
do it the easy way
and I was like ah you know me I like to
do some algebra easy way so it turns out
there's an easier way to do this so I
did this way this is mine I love it my
friend Paul said look all you're doing
is you're looking at P squared minus 1
and asking is that a multiple of 24
every prime squared subtract one is a
multple 24 okay P squared minus one you
may remember this from school or you
could still be in school and you see
that and immediate you think well that's
difference of two squares its P minus 1
P plus 1 if it's been a while since you
did this at school you can just
double-check that if you multiply these
out you'll get back to P squared minus 1
so what we really want to know is is
this a multiple
24 well what can we say about this well
on the number line that's gonna go over
here we're gonna have the number 1 less
than P P minus 1 here we're gonna have
the prime P and then above it we can
have the prime P plus 1 so actually we
got three consecutive numbers here and
the prime in the middle hasn't got any
factors so we know every second number
is a multiple of two so because these
are in a row we know either those two
are a multiple of two or that one's a
multiple of two and this can't be a
multiple of two we know P is not even
because it can't have two as a factor
so both of these numbers have to have a
they're both multiple of two these are
both even numbers in fact because
they're two consecutive even numbers one
of them we don't know which one of them
is a multiple of four so either this
one's a multiple of two this one's a
multiple of four or that one's for and
that one's too right do we know when we
multiply them together the combined
total will be a multiple of eight so now
we know this it is a multiple of eight
because it's two even numbers either
side of a prime and one's for ones too
we have to get eight now we've also got
three numbers in a row and every batch
of three numbers one of them has to be a
multiple of three every third numbers a
multiple of three again it's not the
middle one because we know that when
there is not a multiple of three because
it kind of have 3 as a factor it's a
prime so one of these has to be a
multiple of three again we don't know
which when we multiply them together the
total must be a multiple of three so we
also know that is definitely a multiple
of three and if something is definitely
a multiple of three it's definitely a
multiple of eight it is a multiple of 24
and so that's it just because the two
numbers are either side of a prime if
you multiply them together you get a
number which is a multiple of 24 and
actually we've not really used the fact
that this is a prime all we've used is
the fact that it's not even and it's not
a multiple of three so what we've
actually managed to prove is that all
numbers which don't have two or three as
a factor if you square them you get a
number which is one more than a multiple
of 24 and that
all the ones either side of every single
six so what vaccinations approve is both
all primes are either side of multiple
of six and if you square any number on
either side of a multiple of six
you always get a number which is one
more than a multiple of twenty-four and
that is one of my favorite prime
patterns you said that your friends one
there was easier
it certainly is prettier and it uses
less ink but I'm not sure that would
have been easier to have come up with
that's very true so I'm using easier
probably in a strictly mathematical
sense where I guess easier I'm kind of
using it to mean less turning of the
handle arguably you're right this one is
easier because there's not a lot of
creativity I can say that it's my proof
I can say it all I've done is just
chunked it into predictable categories
and then turn the algebraic handle and
tidied it up and that's my response
where's this one once you've got it is
easier to follow but it wasn't easier to
come up with so I guess I'm saying it's
easier from looking at it in hindsight
not easier coming up with it creatively
in the first place both mathematicians
love a creative proof right and so the
more creative you have to be coming up
with the proof normally the more
impressive mathematicians consider that
proof I like to think you're on
numberphile we go pretty deep into our
topics but I'm also aware sometimes you
want to go even deeper really dive in
today's episode sponsor the great
courses plus is superb for that these
on-demand videos cover everything from
yes mathematics through to other things
like looking after your dog or playing
chess your teachers are going to be
experts from all over the world leading
universities places like that and there
are over 10,000 video courses to choose
from now when I'm going through the site
I've got bit of a weakness for videos
about Egypt Egyptology this one here
decoding the secrets of Egyptian
hieroglyphs this is definitely one to
have a look at it's presented by
Professor Bob Brier who's one of my
favorite egypt explainers he's great
and he's gonna have you writing in
hieroglyphs before you know what's
happening although somehow I doubt
that's the actual rosetta stone behind
him I certainly hope it's not now for a
free trial go to the great courses
plus.com slash numberphile that should
be written on the screen beneath me and
there's also a link down in the video
description where you can find more
information oh by the way that prime
number squaring stuff you just saw a map
talking about that's just one page among
hundreds in Matt's book things to make
and do in the fourth dimension I'll also
include a link to that underneath in the
description